Рекордна кількість кандидатів у президенти України 2019-го, а саме 44,
підштовхує їх винаходити неординарні і дивні обіцянки, щоб виділитися на тлі конкурентів.
Чого тільки політики не присягаються зробити заради голосів виборців -
від бетонної стіни на кордоні з Росією до перейменування України.
Ось топ-п'ять найдивніших обіцянок кандидатів.
На п’ятому місці - намір Ольги Богомолець влаштувати "політичну кастрацію" олігархам,
ізолювати їх соціально і запровадити справедливий податок на розкіш.
Очільниця комітету Верховної Ради України з питань охорони здоров’я і лікарка за освітою
Ольга Боголомець, втім, не уточнює, що означає "політична кастрація",
і як саме вона її буде проводити.
Якщо депутатка має на увазі люстрацію,
то поки в Україні лише почалось очищення влади від високопосадовців часів Віктора Януковича.
І багато чиновників вже оскаржили своє звільнення і поновилися на посадах.
Олігархи ж на держслужбу переважно не йдуть і на політичну ситуацію впливають - опосередковано.
На думку оглядачів, важливо зрозуміти й те, як саме Богомолець планує соціально ізолювати олігархів.
Чи має вона на увазі вивезти їх на окремий острів чи курорт - не уточнюється.
Замість України - Українська народна республіка.
Саме таку зміну назви держави обіцяє кандидат Аркадій Корнацький.
Для чого політику повертати назву УНР -
держави, що проіснувала з 1917-го по 1921-ий рік- незрозуміло.
Найімовірніше, на думку експертів, це популістський крок,
щоб завоювати прихильність патріотично налаштованих українців.
Бетонну стіну та лінію оборони на українсько-російському кордоні
пропонує кандидат Ігор Шевченко, який нещодавно "уславився",
набираючи сині шапки у швейцарському Давосі.
Скільки років кандидат будуватиме бетонну стіну на ділянці завдовжки у майже дві тисячі кілометрів
і скільки на це піде коштів - не уточнює.
А головне - неясно, як зводити стіну на тих понад чотирьохстах кілометрах кордону,
які непідконтрольні Україні через військову агресію Росії.
Стіну між Україною і Росією українцям вже обіцяли - колишний прем’єр Арсеній Яценюк іще у 2014 році.
Однак досі проект виконали менше, ніж на чверть.
А НАБУ розслідує нецільове використання коштів.
У першому ж пункті програми скандально відомого політтехнолога Володимира Петрова
не євроінтеграція і не боротьба з корупцією, а безкоштовний хліб українцям - щодня.
Також він вважає занеобхідне усіма способами повернути Україні споконвічні території,
які нині входять до складу Румунії, Угорщини, Росії, Білорусі таПольщі.
Кандидат не особливо переймається тим, якої думки про такі наміри уряди цих країн.
А от стосовно повернення анексованого Росією Криму
чи окупованих на сході України територій - у програмі кандидата жодного слова.
Не лише хліб, а повний холодильник їжі,
в якому щодня буде м'ясо, обіцяє виборцям кандидат Олег Ляшко.
Як лідер Радикальної партії щодня контролюватиме вміст холодильника 42 мільйонів українців -
не зазначається.
Але цим кандидат не обмежується.
Обіцяє в кожне село по корові - дотації у п'ять тисяч гривень на купівлю худобини.
А ще в січні, під час партійного з'їзду, Ляшко обіцяв повернути смертну кару
та розcтріляти на Майдані 10 корупціонерів, щоб інші боялись брати хабарі.